Martin Van Buren said the less
government interferes with private
pursuits the better for general
prosperity you know government
interferes with private pursuits there's
several different ways or
over-regulation is one and most people
don't feel like we are under regulated
if you do but they're generally the
people that like to run HOAs anyway the
other way government of fear interferes
with private pursuits is by taking your
money
it's called taxation excessive taxation
is excessive interference and there's no
question we're in an over regulated in
excessive taxation environment and
that's not because that we hate poor
people on the contrary poor people are
best served by any institution other
than the government and that would
include communities that would include
churches that would include individuals
and by the way that's biblical there's
nowhere in Scripture nowhere in
Scripture that the government is used to
care for those who are marginalized as
an act of charity so somehow we've
gotten a group of people who have
equated increased taxation as a
charitable act for the poor and it's not
a lot of debate and talk about that with
the GOP tax bill passing this weekend
and gone to conference so we'll see what
it ends up being doesn't appear to be
that big a change and it's really
interesting that you know the griping
and the whining and the carping from
both sides of the aisle
I mean I'm amazed as some of you friends
of mine that are you know big-time
conservatives have lost their ability to
think clearly
in the name of politics I guess it's
always been that way I guess I'm getting
old and I'm just observing the whole
Trump and Hillary debacle where we had
two horrible candidates of horrible
character and we were supposed to choose
between them and really you were left
with choosing not the person in either
case but in the instead in the ideology
that you believed in the the ideas or
the issues that they believe in and
trying to align yourself with one of
those or the other and you were stuck
with that but you know in the middle of
that there's people that actually are
enthralled with the heat with the
quality of their either one I'm his
character which is just astounding to me
it's just astounding that you would
really look at either one of them's
character and go oh my gosh that is just
a virtuous person come on you've got to
be kidding me
yeah it's amazing people just lose their
I mean I have friends who you know if
you don't say that Trump is the most
wonderful man that's ever lived then you
know and that all everything negative
that's ever been said about him is alive
they won't hardly speak to you anymore
that's absurd some surd and I know other
people feel the same way about Hillary
and that's absurd so it's just people
have lost their minds out here I don't
know whether it's a 24/7 news cycle with
these news channels just constantly
trying to drum up ratings by making you
angry at the other side but it in
regardless of that you're still
responsible for your critical thought so
you know what where does all that come
from the less government interferes with
private pursuits the better for general
prosperity martin van buren interesting
another thing that's interesting to me I
was thinking about this morning the
people that are so against capitalism
and are for this wealth inequality
movement generally call themselves
progressives and the people that run
Facebook I think
we can all safely say they're
progressives and the people that run
Amazon I think we can all safely say
they're progressives I mean Bezos
Zuckerberg right people running Apple I
think you can safely say they're
progressives people running Google I
think you can safely say they're
progressives liberals four of the
biggest most controlling companies in
the world and very successful provide
incredible I do business with every one
of them I mean they're they provide
incredible service and we work with
Google we work with Apple products we
work with them and I'm not personal
friends with these guys but very
interesting that I mean very very
left-wing and so if you believe in
wealth inequality you know at least tell
you Teddy Roosevelt probably the first
progressive probably would break up all
four of those companies they're pretty
much the standard oil of our day I mean
you you technically under antitrust they
don't fall there but if the four of them
if they all want to move against
something in an industry that they're in
it pretty much wipes the slate clean I
mean it's like a glacier coming through
it scrapes everything off and so it's
very interesting to me that these
progressives run this these liberals run
these things and everybody just stands
back and does business with them left
and right
which is awesome I'm not mad about it
I'm doing business with them I think
they all provide good service every one
of them I mean you know Microsoft in
there if you want to - Bill Gates right
that's you know another another liberal
other concern not a conservative you
know and so four or five of the most
successful largest businesses that
completely owned and dominate I mean
completely dominate and they didn't
pound the rail of their spaces they
Facebook there's just there's none of em
II it's complete there's a complete
domination Google complete domination
Apple's close you know and certainly
Amazon just wiping entire industries out
left and right and it's just competition
it's the way it works I'm not mad about
it but it's just it's it's it's
intriguing to me that some of you that
are left wingers
don't think anything about those four
companies are five companies and you
don't think anything about the fact that
the beginning of the progressive
movement for all practical purposes from
an economic standpoint for sure was
Teddy Roosevelt the breaking up of the
monopolies the standard oil's the robber
baron this is what he called them
the JP Morgan's right and so on and I
don't I don't agree with it but I don't
agree with monopolies but you know these
guys are technically not in violation of
antitrust don't misunderstand but they
control their space they control their
space and it's just interesting that we
do get so caught up in our point of view
that we not only don't hear the other
side but we more importantly than not
hearing this I don't have any desire to
listen to people who are wrong I get
that on any issue with that but I'm
intrigued by the fact that we've lost
our ability to critically think through
something because we get so caught up in
pigeonholing
ourselves like you know if I'm for
conservative values I automatically have
to worship Donald Trump and I got to
tell you I don't and yet I'm definitely
economically conservative socially I'm a
conservative I'm probably economically a
libertarian probably because I would go
with Martin Van Buren here the less
government interferes with private
pursuits the better for general
prosperity it's kind of an economic
statement right it's very interesting
times we live in you guys but my
challenge for you guys are listeners
it's not to make you mad if you want to
get mad I mean that's getting line crap
there's a whole bunch of people mad at
me it generally means though that you
got your head stuck so far up your
politics you can't think anymore and
that's what we keep running into you
know I actually I mean I know people who
are respect their intellect who have
slipped a gear man they have lost their
ability to think through things all
through the paradigm of Republican or
Democrat conservative or liberal Trump
or Hillary and they get twisted in that
and then they try to use some kind of
toxic version of scripture to justify
their existence oh my goodness gracious
you are really reaching there
Wow yeah you need to establish what you
believe independent of the personalities
that are involved including this one
learn to think for yourself ah that's
what we teach you around here all the
time and we'll help you either way by
the way if your left-wing wacko I'll
help you if you're a right-wing like oh
I'll help you we love you and we're here
to take care of you that's what we'll do
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]